hey there I'm Ryan assault alongside
former NFL Pro Bowler tony richardson
and andrew pearl off and today we're
talking about the future of the NFL
sports illustrated has partnered with
wired magazine on a project called Super
Bowl 100 as we take a look at what the
game of football in the NFL will look
like 30-40 even 50 years down the road
they drew seen the game seemed so much
just a few years Tony been retired from
the NFL what what prediction do you have
for the future of info for you look at
you know the way the league is going now
it's very much more wide open basketball
and turf they say that's the evolution
the entire NFL used to be guys with just
run into each other then they invented
the past piece of all the injuries and
then through the years it's been more
passing more wide-open footballs and
steadily evolving over the last century
and now it's been quickly evolving this
century I see more basketball turf I
don't think they'll go to a weight limit
I think that'll be discussed I think
safety is really gonna be the main topic
moving forward they could do certain
things you know linux blitzing I don't
know what they're gonna do but they're
gonna try and take hits out of the game
and you say well there's nothing they
can do but look what they've done the
last several years they've taken it out
I think obviously they changed the
kickoff I think pretty soon I don't take
the kickoff out of the game yeah I used
to be one of those Gunners on on I guess
the headhunter on kickoff the r5 we have
to go in there blasting so offensive
lineman and double teams and things that
nature that's totally out and you see
the target you know target Iser who you
could hit you talk about it just keeps
shrinking and then people would say wait
you can't touch the quarterback now but
we said that about ten years ago and
guess what they made the rules even more
restrictive I see them head in that
direction maybe not just you're talking
about pump plays they're gonna find
little tweaks here and there try and
make the game as safe as possible and
the other thing we're not talking about
too is technology to Ken this is more
for you can they can they make a safer
helmet as a player do you want to say
for helmet maybe they really require
certain things uniform wise and helmet
why's that could help although they do
stuff now they could always do more yeah
I was on The Players Association when we
started researching helmets we started
looking at masks are homeless and just
really trying to do the research and
stand how can mass
Dr Irwin you know into a wall going over
100 miles an hour and get out and skate
but yeah we can run down the football
field and have a collision and we're
kind of banged up but then it was
starting to get into the weight of the
helmet and different things like that
they're still testing these helmets out
now I think this is one thing that the
NFL has on their side to feel good about
going forward is technology knowledge
continually is advancing look how much
has happened the last 10 20 years in the
NFL I looked at some product yesterday
at the center that if your head is
accelerated to a certain speed whether
it decreases or accelerates to a certain
speed a red light goes off and
immediately you're pulled out of the
game and I think you know pop warner
teams are adapting to that the NFL has
not gone that route obviously but with
the evolution of technology so quick so
many talented scientists out there I
think that bodes well that may be that
the future of the sport is in the hands
of guys that have nothing to do with
football guys that are sitting there in
labs and in in factories so to speak
absolutely I mean Tony cited NASCAR
obviously we know the fatality rate has
gone down with the odds of ice and you
know the same thing hopefully could
happen before I agree with you
completely technology always changes the
game you know it's changed instant
replay now we can see everything and I
mean it's I know you have a hundred-yard
feel that you're starting with but
they're going to attack it with
everything they have and I can't see
anything but having a big impact on the
game
you